are you cool Carlos Mencia now
I just want to bring up your whole pass
we had him on here I know yeah we had a
moment I watched it but I'm saying that
was like that was over a year ago I have
to say I just have love for him he took
you on the road though right
he I learned everything from him
I learned everything from him and he got
you a car I know I learned everything
from him I was generally asking no and
I'm genuinely answered this is the first
question about that though yeah go ahead
like sincerely from Comics is isn't it
has it not been long enough like he's
been in comedy jail for so long isn't it
time that maybe just let him out
like he was never in my jail no he's not
in my jail I know but you know what I
mean whose jail is Ian like everybody
else everyone else's jail
yeah I mean like how much longer does
someone need to be I was my thing with
with that whole situation you just fart
yeah sorry did she just fart yeah holy
you heard it from there
I told you uh sorry oh you fart any
other guest all the time oh you think
that's disrespectful no I thought you
and I were gay I thought if we were gay
that's so serious and we slept in the
same bed together yeah
I would cover it and I'll trap you in
with the fart with the shoe he used to
do that
yeah but you and you and I would giggle
like little boys do for you
that's what we would
I say did we
did now I know where this is coming from
uh he did everything for me yeah
everything every hole yeah what what he
um I think he should uh I think the
problem with him is that if he would
just apologize
and just move on and that was such a
weird age right now like like literally
if you can just own whatever your
fuck-ups are yeah right
people people don't really care
well I think they can move on I don't
know because I still read his comments
and people still comment
people hold on let me ask you this yeah
God when you say read comments because
we all
I always think the people that are going
in on people there were people that were
never going to come see you anyways live
no they were never gonna pay to see
anyways yeah so you're really holding
their their opinion a little too strong
also Mitzi said to me
I've said this a million times on this
podcast I'll say it again it's worth
repeating
it's worth a break you're not a star
unless half the people love you and half
the people hate you
you just never had that conversation
with her yeah
around the conversation talking to four
[__] and we never heard of them yeah
yeah but she would give throw a little
bit like you know I mean she would also
say it is a sin to support mediocrity
and I asked her I go what does that mean
she goes well you know if you see a
comic who's not good and you say good
job that's not good so why does she
support those four [__]
I think she had lost her mind like she
started losing some of her faculties do
you remember who they were and did they
ever no it was Chelsea Handler Whitney
[__]
yeah for like a year then she got
you doing now I haven't heard her
forever she's in Vegas right she's in
Vegas what's she doing well she was
doing shows with The Carrot Top really
yeah yeah never knew that yeah yeah
opening for Carrot Top